[Music]
I'm sure you've all heard about Spanx
now you're probably wondering what you
know where's he going with this how does
this possibly link to anything he's
brought up before well the very popular
stretchy undergarment that didn't make
people look thinner well I just read
that Spanx this is in the news can push
on your internal organs and may actually
cause major health problems this is a
story now now I'm not saying that Spanx
are necessarily dangerous but until we
know more who in their right mind would
continue wearing Spanx every day doesn't
make sense I mean what kind of person
puts their own personal vanity above
simple common sense maybe they're just
deeply insecure and they think that
looking thinner will compensate for
their personal and professional
shortcomings if they really think
wearing Spanx is gonna fool anyone into
thinking they're thin they're either
very naive or just very very stupid I
even hear there are some incredibly vain
people who wear two pairs of Spanx pull
them all the way up to their chest and
God knows what kind of internal damage
that does to them it's insane
[Applause]
[Music]
can you recognize it down in he
[Applause]
he went for that joke he bled for that
joke can I can I go home now oh your
stay keep bleeding from the mouth for
the whole show
nice to meet you at law
that's so funny man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
anybody tuning in halfway through the
show
sleeping well yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]